hi
for people who are joining this live
stream we are
doing a review of some welcome language
functionality
um but i'm surprised there's still 12.3
stuff being discussed but i guess
12.3 is on its way out the door
um and there'll be some future stuff
here
okay success and failure objects right
so we added a note
to success and failure which isn't quite
right
because failure has
so maybe if you open the the ref page
um it'll be easier to
do can i open the the built rough page
or do i have to open the source
uh the the source one should be fine at
least for failure
with success it's more recent so it
might not
okay right so we added that first note
there last time to document this
behavior that was sort of only
documented
in via examples okay um
but it's a that note isn't quite right
at least for failure it's true for
success
but it's not for failure because failure
has this these
additional magic properties that don't
come from the association
um in particular uh
well they're listed in the agenda there
hold message template message message
name styled message
and they might they might vary a little
bit but they're all sort of
message related okay well then why don't
we just say prop
there extracts a certain property you
know part of it is the tag
the keys in the in the actual failure
association another
in addition this blah blah blah
um right so
that i get well one question is you know
should success have these same
magic properties or
or not and then um
yes and then how exactly do we want to
tweak the note to uh
yeah we can we can give prop uh we can
change
key to prop right we can't we'll have to
remove
the explosive list of the sock there
right because they're
they're not necessarily coming from a
sock um you want me to do the edit here
well i was you know if if you have
strong opinions if not i guess i can try
to come up with something
yeah i mean we just need to it's hard
for me to do because of my computer
mess ups here and i i can try and let me
try and do
let me update the documentation so i
don't miss something
i mean if you just say
um
and i can write this i'm sure you can
write it too i i i'm
okay um right and then the the other
question is
is this discrepancy between success and
failure
is there a message for success there
isn't really
um
[Music]
there uh i think there can be
really i mean it's an interesting idea
to have a message for success but i
don't know of
that existing um
yeah i mean we modeled it off of what we
have for failure with the ability to
have a message template and parameters
but it's not strictly required
again you know failure came first and
was modeled on
the messaging template system for for
messages being more descriptive
a success object doesn't need to have a
message template in it but it
right but right but it might right it
might say you know
uh you know sent mail with
id blah blah blah right so it's not it's
not necessarily a message message
but it it can use a
a message name to sort of format what
it's saying
um but if we're i guess if we're okay
with the
and i guess ricardo who you know this is
pretty late for him so i don't know if
he's actually
no i mean um
you know you my understanding of of what
you were saying is that you thought this
was really useful and that we should add
it to success
well yeah i mean the experience of how
we have been using it
i mean we have been using it
successfully in the in the in
interpreter failure and and and what
message is doing is that it allows you
to have a unique
interface to extract the english message
out of it i mean
english or internationalized this is why
basically we have this design where
the template can be uses most of the
time rule delay that you just reference
a message
so that in the future you can you know
attach different
translations to it and so the idea is
that you
you have this unique interface yes to
basically render it in in in a context
where basically
you don't render the whole failure but
you just render the message for the
final user like
what we are doing it forms and so if you
have a unique interface to extract it
you know um
it's easier for uh
yeah to to basically extract it in
easily
in the right place by using this
interface and uh
i think it makes sense for the success
as well um
okay so right so that's obviously not
for 12.3 because we're not going to just
throw in that implementation but i i
just
at the time you know making sure the
documentation isn't lying
was was 12 30. so i'll just why don't we
do this well
i'll rework reword things right
you know if there's still if there's
still an issue after i've worded things
obviously we'll need to wait for the
implementation if there's still an issue
there we'll we'll bring it back
okay okay
all right so the second thing is um
i realized we didn't actually knit
progress reporting and dollar progress
reporting
um i i i honestly don't remember if i
actually added it to tuning and
debugging or if i just meant to
and didn't um
so we might want to look at that page
and then the only question is is there
some other
some other place this fits it didn't
seem
obvious where but you know
since it was only one page i came up
with i wanted to solicit
opinions on uh on that
well does did it get um
shouldn't this link to things like echo
i suppose it could it uh
it's
and maybe echo
could in turn link to progress reporting
right you know in a sense echo is more
analogous to the internal evaluated
progress which we haven't quite figured
out how to expose
yet but
well we'll change that later
all right where is echo let me ask by
elephant why
who's kind of a bit awol right now
because of my
screens problem so i can use my elephant
successfully here um
time measurement and optimization
that seems like a relevant section
oh wow i did not even see that one when
i was looking for
symbols but yes okay
tuning and debugging you've got that one
by the way this probably should have
a link to dollar progress reporting
okay did you insert it on this page yet
or not
like i said i honestly don't remember so
um but i would have
made it given it the 12 free market so
apparently i
didn't okay
yeah it's sort of i think it goes here
yeah it was just going to say next to
princeton for
maybe down here okay
okay so we should just say dollar
progress reporting
so there's dollar progress reporting
which is the sort of global default and
then there's progress reporting which is
the option name
that you can override with
right um
specify default
progress reporting
for various for system functions
that reasonable sounds reasonable to me
okay here
so maybe
kind of feel like what we can do here
let's just say progress reporting a
dollar progress reporting
is it called progress reporting the
option name
yep
okay
all right what's next
right so right we've changed uh i guess
i forgot to include an example
but we've changed the store now button
for summary boxes right so if you do
sparse array of 10 to the 7th
you should now see the new of range of
10 to the 7th
you should now see the new uh
you know the new button the new
appearance with the additional x
actions
and right so it will now give you an
option you know several
oh is that is mute button
yeah it doesn't look great what happens
when you click
okay it is the new button okay for some
reason
oh the icon moved for both of them okay
so that that's where i got confused
right so you have this shiny new button
um why does that icon there
agree with the first icon in this list
here
um just seems wrong
store now it should just be a chevron
there
and also the placement of this seems
very funky and also
the fact that this didn't respond to
magnification is disappointing um
billy any opinions on that
uh those weren't part of the
we could we could update the embed
inline and notebook
icon or or leave it in favor of removing
it from the
from the button and with the uh chevrons
as you said
um but i think i think we can keep it
um because it kind of says what it's
doing
yeah right i think right well
i think i think this will actually
connect to to the question
next question which is so for data set
we
did not change its store now button in
part because
it comes in two different sizes so i you
know
at least for the full size button it
could look
you know if we're okay with it it could
look and behave
just like the yeah one thing
bothering me is the semicolon has you
know
it should be a period if it's going to
have a capital letter after it
yeah that's definitely true so let's
change it to
period please noted okay
i i think we should ditch the small like
version for data set okay so
um i mean if it's it's only going to be
attached to large data sets anyway which
are likely to be wide
and if it's if it's wider than the data
set then
it just hangs out i don't think that's a
problem i think we should just get rid
of the small button
are you sure even for these weird little
cases
well you know it's for large data sets i
think it's unlikely to
yeah it probably will never be seen in
the wild
it's like a um and if it is it's not
it's just not a big deal it just hangs
out a little bit
[Music]
i think given that we've built this
capability i don't know of the cases
where
there'll be a thing like this that's
elegantly sitting there
and then it somehow
i don't know i feel i feel like it's um
um right i i guess the other question
is you know what happens after you store
it and say a local object right because
we give it the little badge
saying what local object it's in
right so in the summary box yeah if you
actually go ahead and select save and
local object
then you'll see what the final state
looks like
so so so
yeah because i about you you need to
reevaluate it in the current session
right but i'm saying right so
if you start a notebook and if you start
in the notebook it just
didn't give me any choice
that was the starting point of this
discussion we haven't changed anything
when data set okay um
but in the summary box if you store
um store it in a local object
right so we now have that
um so would we keep that as a little
hanging
thing on on the
on the data set are we okay with that
yeah i think so okay
i don't quite understand why we have
this here i i think that should be
underneath it should be in the blob up
here
storage location local object or
something
because it just it's just going to work
at this point
i mean to have that be a big loud thing
an a-local object you know i hate doing
it this way
in
right but no no i hate this a and then
this ridiculous extra space there
local object it's either english in
which case it's local space object with
lowercase l and lowercase o
or it's
right well i mean that thing is is a
button right you can actually extract
the local object
i mean the a b indefinitely how do i
extract the local object
oh
then what i think we should do is say
data stored in
cut out the a local object open bracket
dot dot dot
okay okay
do you want a colon or just
no i think it's okay to just say okay
like i'll get stored in
in i know data stored in local object
open bracket
whatever
okay
okay so we'll we'll we'll right so we'll
make that change for local object and
cloud object
and also the colon uh i mean the
semicolon that should be a period
yup and then i
think chris has everything he needs from
our side to just make the changes
to the data set but if he needs
assistance of course lou and i
are available to provide that assistance
i this is a mean loud yeah
go ahead i was gonna ask what was the
decision on that
that tag you said you wanted to be in
the blob but if it is in the blob that
won't work for data set
all right that's fine but i would like
it to be less bright blue here
to be a little bit tamer you know
less dramatic once it's stored i think
we can be less dramatic about where it's
stored and so on
well but it's it's it's it's not there
there
right right if you sent me this notebook
right now it would be useless to me
i said just like i said okay all right
okay
okay i'm sold okay
okay what's next all right so i think
the next item
uh is uh the rob
item uh yep um
which is uh
a web of interrelated issues
this looks painful yes well this
this is lcc it's where we deal with the
painful issues
okay fine okay
okay is rob here yes he is
okay okay
explain the issue
so right now we have two you know we we
have different behaviors among
different functions uh
and and so one inconsistency is shown
right there between unit triangle and
heavy side lambda which are
you know what they're percent point wise
they're basically the same function it's
just that one is
the you know just the piecewise defined
function and the other
is uh okay so you're saying if i do this
that's going to give an exact integer
right and that all and it always gives
an example i know i know i know i know
so the question is these functions were
where
where you know it's it's it it should be
you know it's basically in the technical
language it's the functions of compact
support
so the functions which we know you know
which have some value
in uh in some range but outside of that
range we know our exact
uh you know are definitely zero should
it be a machine zero
or should it be for consistency with the
other part of the range or should it be
an
exact zero because we know they're
really zero
i understand okay so rob what what are
the places where this entangles
well so so so so this came off as you
know mark brought this up as a
as a discussion is if if we want to if
we if we want to
to compile you know compile things
generally it's a compiler issue it's a
compiler issue
of whether this what what the type
signature of this function is correct
and we want to be
this i mean if we can if we can strive
to be as tight consistent as possible
right you know what we're not going to
achieve that so that's a problem for the
compiler
right well i don't
think if you think we're going to change
the semantics for the sake of having it
be
a little bit easier for today's compiler
to not have to use type unions we're not
going to do it
right because i just don't believe in it
i mean the fact is
it's not beyond the capability of the
compiler to deal with it it can use type
unions
right yes but
okay so don't tell me that it has to be
done that way because it's like
okay well there i mean there are other i
mean there are
other issues so well right now we have
inconsistency right
i mean plot unit triangle and button no
i get it but but what
rob is making is let's change them all
so that they are
type signature consistent okay good for
the compiler bad for other things i'm
not saying change
everything i'm saying when when there's
a decision to be made
like this change it to be type
consistent when it's reasonable to do so
no i mean look i'm sorry
but the okay look
okay what is the complete inventory of
cases
um i don't have that handy
it's probably five to ten functions
i mean here here are two of them
uh i am unclear okay these two examples
unit triangle and so on these are not
i mean what i worry about
is is things where the next thing we
have is bool for example
or or inverse bool or whatever it's
called
right where it's like oh that's zero
point
oh what do i do
am i making sense um
doesn't bull always give an
well it's the thing that goes from zero
one to true false
uh which is
i forget i'm not sure we ever have
inverse bull but we have um
i'm not sure we have that play there
um right we have unitizing we have bull
i don't know well maybe we maybe we
maybe we missed that
i mean and um maybe we don't have that
but but you get what i'm saying that
there's a
there'll be a chain of things right and
and let me point out that
the the the the unit triangle behavior
changed at some point it was originally
returning machine zeros and then it
started returning okay why did we change
it
no i i have asked i have not gotten an
answer so then we need to look at the
pull request and see what
well there was ancient i mean there
weren't there's no poor request
how anciently was it changed uh
version seven or eight maybe
a bit things will be already being
pulled by version seven and eight
no they weren't no they weren't but but
there there would be a commit message
right
okay cvs not
okay well it cannot be built for 2008.
okay so um right so i guess it was
i mean now you is there a link to the
bug report
there yeah there there well it's not a
link there's plug number three
eight one five nine why don't we look it
up but
but okay so let me understand this the
issue is
there are okay is it would it be
consistent
okay so one assertion is
reels should map to reels even when the
function knows
that i i don't understand how you can
support that because
you know piecewise for instance
you know that's a user-defined thing
whether for x greater than zero it's
zero versus zero point and so on
making sense rob you understand what i'm
saying
i don't i don't understand what you're
saying
look if you make the principle that
anytime there's
there's an exact input in
it's going to give an exact input out
you can't do that for piecewise for
example
because piecewise the user has
explicitly given the output value
sure which is why there's a suggestion
of having if the user wants to create a
type consistent
piecewise that we should have a function
that gives the correct zero
why is it just an issue of a zero why is
an issue for one
half three quarters whatever else
um because because
typically because uh
typically the right the the
the branches that give the other
things um
i've got this case here right
and i and i say i feed into that
let's say
does this work does it have the correct
precedence no it doesn't
no pointing would have been swank
uh okay so in this case
i do this
okay right but this is a function that
always returns an exact result
which is fine right the the
the point okay you do unit if you do
unit triangle of you know
0.5 look look look look look this case
right i can get exactly the same as you
right there
oops minus 0.7
down thesaurus it's inexact
sure
right but right now there isn't a good
way for a user to provide the default
zero
yeah i mean i think that's perfectly
fine it's
i think the point is that if we have a
function like unit triangle
they could have floating point values
everywhere reasonably
why shouldn't it
i'm sorry default i'm sorry look the
case here
is
there are functions that have built-in
default values that's what you're saying
i mean another example is ram
ram
minus 1.0
yeah for goodness sake
right so for example right so it's
probably
more common for you know our our math
functions to be
type consistent and that sensual
triangle is really
real you know an outlier
okay well maybe okay well maybe it
should be considered a bug i suppose
is it consistent to make these few
functions type consistent
i i think so okay
um then what's all this stuff i just
don't believe in this
i mean why isn't there a one as well as
a zero as well as in everything else
because the default return value of
piecewise
is uh is exact
zero so so
you know it is much more common to want
to provide a default
zero but it could be a default it could
be a default one as well i don't know
yeah i i think the issue and i i could
have this wrong
is that um it's easier to propagate the
precision to
non-zero than it is for zero in
particular
accuracy for zero is i'm aware but
that's not what this is about this is
about inexact versus exact
there's no precision for an exact one
see what i'm saying there's a different
issue
no no but but my point is that it's it's
easier to code
the type consistency between input and
output
for non-zero results than it is to code
it for zero
i think that was the claim in the email
thread
right because all you need to do is
multiply by one dot and you you have
as long as the other bits are not exact
zero
okay so speak speak to this rob because
that that
that's a the reason
i like that is zero is not i mean
sure there's potential uses there i mean
it's easy enough to have a
[Music]
you know in the compiler it's essential
to have a con we have a constant zero
and a constant one
um both which are which are quite useful
particularly the constant zero what
about constant two
um multiplied by two yeah
right um so but you can always
so so anything anything where you want a
zero and you want either an exact zero
or machine zero
which is the most common case you can
just multiply
you know multiply so you're proposing
something
0 so i get it i get it it's a piece of
complete hackery
it's basically what's being explained
i mean the thing you asked for isn't the
thing you really want
the thing you want is
some kind of weird
it's because you don't have a way to
make an
exact number out of zero
oh well wally okay okay so in the
consider
um you know consider it right you have
a piecewise that's you know with it
which defaults to zero outside a certain
range but you might
want a you know exact zero if it's exact
a a machine real if it's
uh you know if it's if the input is a
machine real
uh machine complex if it's uh okay okay
whatever yeah or or
or even you know a quantity of zero
meters instead of exact zero if the
input is a quantity in meters
so what's your point i'm saying having a
function that returns the correct zero
based on the input
is is a useful operation
nobody would be forced to use it but for
what functions would it be provided
for for users to write their own
piecewise functions
so it would be an option to piecewise
what it will be an option to piece wise
well not an option option but yes it
would be something that people could use
in piecewise
how would it work what would it look
like the default case would be
right you know zero of x
that seems like a function to me yes
that is what we're talking about these
are
right zero and constant zero are
functions are they not rob
yeah they're they're functions right
this is what we're talking about we're
talking about a function
named zero or constant zero or you know
steven's most favorite zero
um that takes an input and based on the
input returns an appropriate
zero it is not a constant
okay it's a convenience for multiplying
by
exact zero um
and in some sense it's not really
necessary
oh it's a thing that maps
yes the pipe
type of a thing
onto a zero of that same type so what
you're saying is
that if i said zero of
5 meters
this would return 0 meters is that
correct right
okay so it's it's sort of in the
what does unitized do
unitize is kind of essentially the
inverse boolean were talking about
it either makes a it either makes a one
or a zero
[Music]
okay
so
this operation
it's kind of a it has a certain
projective character to it the zero
operation that you're describing but the
zero opera
the definition of the zero operation is
you can
you can write out a rule so zero of
x underscore colon equals zero
times x
so it's just that it's it's sort of a
reading convenience thing for that
wait that's nonsense that's just
nonsense
look yeah this times this oh it does
give zero
yeah exactly it and and it's really
useful for this cases so it could be
more efficient than actually doing
multiplication but
but that's your problem in the compiler
right that's your problem you fixed that
right well the problem the reason for
having a zero is that most people don't
realize that multiplying an exact zero
by something
gives the the natural zero
and it's also not very realistic like
you'd look and say well
why am i multiplying this thing by zero
that seems like a bizarre thing to do
i had no idea either yeah well if you
didn't know
how are our core users supposed to have
a chance
[Music]
okay so if the implementation really is
just multiplying
by by exactly zero problems as a
function
what sorry although
i guess right i guess i guess the one
advantage is
is if it's symbolic it could stay
unevaluated
right so one issue is right if you do if
you do zero
x slash dot x goes to you know
quantity of four meters then you'll get
an exact
zero rather than zero meters
that's right you that's that's actually
a really good point you tie so it
it it avoids the evaluation of exact
zero
times x when you have x as a placeholder
right which would just give zero exactly
exactly
okay the name zero is off the table
if we can come up with a really good
name which explains what it is
i mean this is such an unbelievably
confusing thing it's not even
it's just not even funny i mean it's
ridiculous
okay so what is this doing
it's some kind of
oh boy what is this doing
i mean
it's more or less this but i don't like
that
that name is horrifying as well
it's closer to that isn't it right
i was thinking like make zero or
matching zero
um
zero if i
the worst zero
it's an exotic looking word
zero eyes we can't have zero eyes
because it does the opposite thing from
united eyes
what was the thing brett just said
zeroed
that's better
that's actually not bad yeah i liked it
all right what's the description zero to
facts
makes a version of x
returns a zero of the same type as x
or the same but returns a zeroed version
of x of the same type of
x or something
all right we got two things here all
right so i guess we can consider this
function zeroed
and we should probably despite my
protestations earlier
fix this type consistency for these
functions that have
default values
yeah i mean i can ask mark if he has a
longer list
than than you know these guys
but i i like i said i you know i
over the past year i've reviewed the
docs for you know
200 something uh
math functions and i only came up with
you know unit try off the top of my head
i remember in a triangle and maybe
one or you know i have some big sense
there were one or two
others but it's it's going to be a bunch
of others in the ramp
family
i mean you know what we where
i mean the other place where we have
type inconsistency
are are things that you know suddenly
return
you know pies or indeterminates
and those those are more mathematically
meaningful
and and and so i think you know that's
but here where it's really just zero
versus zero dot i'm like
i think you know why not make right
why unpack just because you know
some of your numbers had to be bigger
let us continue
okay catenate the life and times
ethan on our live stream says cat nate
doesn't work on sparse array objects it
certainly should
okay well yeah yes i mean
uh yeah cat nate is a is a
weird and
to my mind not terribly compelling
function right oh it's very very very
useful
i use it all the time okay i i have
never found myself wanting to use okay
so i'll tell you why i use it
okay okay um
it is basically the use of flatum
which does not default to level one is a
number one source of bugs and functions
of mine
okay i use catalyte to avoid that
i you know i just found caffeinate
really useful in many many
different then apply apply platinum
level one
right well i mean why why isn't it
join right it doesn't join because join
doesn't take that out of the list
right it's applied mine isn't it i mean
yes it is
okay fine and that's that's it's simple
to make it work for sparse rays by
implementing it as applied joint fine
yeah
um but uh the uh right and the other
thing it does
right is it expects the values of
associations
which right so cat nate of association
doesn't return association
returns and i presume
i guess i i've never tested this can you
combine a list of
lists and associations um
so if in that first example if you if
you add one of those to be
change one of those to be an association
will it still work
well sure the the third example has that
oh oh yeah it does you're right i missed
that
it's about example it should say three
four
um but um
yeah so the uh right so i guess it does
the auto values
bit um right right so so so
should i take a level spec i mean i i
suppose in principle could it's a little
bit weird because
you know most things that take a level
spec take arbitrary heads and this most
definitely does not it wants a list
of things let's understand what it's
think of it more like a linear algebra
function or something or a
list i mean okay what would it mean what
would the level spec mean
i think the level spec would mean
the correct level spec like just two
would mean
catenate in a sequence all the things
that live at level two right
which is i guess equivalent to going
levels one through two
isn't it
do you get what i'm saying uh i'm not
sure i entirely followed that
i mean i i guess my my my belief was
that it would more or less mirror
what levels that's mean and join right
that you're joining at those levels but
maybe that's not right join does join
have a level spike
yes
but of course like i said it's not a
general level spec it's just
it's just me oh that's a horrifying
stupid thing i hate those
successive levels
join by concatenating
i'm sure there there's an example in
scope
well so apply caffeinate i mean sorry
catinate as apply join
could work the same way is that true
i i think so i i don't think not this
reason why it couldn't it would actually
be nicer in terms of that
level specification than joining us
right all right well let's let's
investigate that possibility then
okay
um right i i think that's probably going
to work i'd have to think through all
the examples but i think that's probably
going to work
to have catenate comma n be
something that basically joins the
objects at level n
in each of the lists of i mean it's
basically the same wording as this
except that the lesser by here
in an overall list
okay all right anything else
well i i feel like i should apologize to
the audience though because we've made
it through the whole agenda
in like 48 minutes and i wasn't prepared
for that
what did you think was going to hold us
up by these these
well i i thought that the early ones
would go pretty fast it's just
normally i prepare some agenda and by
five o'clock where
we're or maybe halfway through it so uh
right
but if anybody in the audience feels
like they didn't get their money's worth
i apologize for
preparing to sort an agenda
right um okay okay
with respect to 12 3 i mean there's no
more stuff
left to talk about for that is that
correct
uh i mean it's just documentation tweaks
um unless we think we want to try to get
the
the the data set change to be live for
12.3
but nice so i i don't know what's in the
christmas which aspect of that i mean i
i
we we have the general labeling there
right well just making it we'll accept
the new
the new uh multiple choices for for
death
right i think that's nice but not super
critical
okay um
question in general i mean the list of
things
that are being lcc'd for example
uh the useful round across the system
who thinks they're dealing with going to
hunt down the use of around the use of
units
even across the system who thinks
they're hunting down those
those dependencies
um
[Music]
well i don't know
[Music]
i don't know that anybody thinks
there is i mean
okay it's mostly me right lcc is
basically me
and yeah i understand i understand but
i'm asking is that going to be delegated
to the statistics group is that where is
that
uh well i uh jose is on pto
today so i mean i think uh
i think around is is maybe statistics
but certainly
jose would have a better answer on terms
of
in terms of quantity i think we've made
i mean i think we've done i mean there's
still some work in like the core
algorithmic things you know the poor
math things
to better handle units but i think nick
can disagree with me
but i think we've done a pretty good job
of propagating it out but now it's just
sort of
individual functions here and there
where we where we spot issues
so like eigenvalues for example does it
work though
well eigenvalues uh
i eigenvalues
maybe i mean with me with linear algebra
there are issues that
right it typically needs to be all the
same unit
and so or or
right it's not a consistent problem um
and so
we haven't made the big question to uh
into linearity there's a quantity array
so let me say determinant of that array
oh nice right now i say
inverse of that array
nice right if i say eigenvalues
very nice right so so those work
more you know more abstract and yes in
fact eigen system
works as well i remember now and it puts
the units in the right place
um you know some of the like some of the
matrix decompositions it's not clear
where the units go and that that's where
it gets messier
so that that's why maybe not all of the
linear algebra ones understand
so which ones don't what doesn't know
where it's where its
units go you know like uh uh
by the way i'm sorry i'm sorry look at
that see the bottom of that
that thing it's missing its foot
that's a that's a known issue i think
that it's been recently fixed
right but if you do something like qr
detox
this isn't right this is right
the the the the eigenvectors are
dimensionless
and the eigenvalues are dimension full
yeah that's the only way you can report
a meters in the eigenvalue
i see okay okay but if you try something
like qr decomposition i don't know if it
will much
less defined even there it seems to know
something
so it knows something right and
obviously if you had a matrix where
is that unique i'm sorry in this case
here is that unique
could i have dimensionless eigenvalues
and dimension full matrix
yes so that's a convention
right but for eigen eigenvalues it makes
the most
sense that you want right but yes right
but
certainly at the more sensible
convention right i mean the eigenvalues
are the physical observables and
the eigenvectors are just abstract
state projections in fact aren't the
eigenvectors
normalized to have norm one so how could
they have units
right again that's by convention
but it's a perfectly reasonable that's a
very good point as soon as you're
normalizing them they couldn't possibly
have units right
okay but what if i look at some fancier
statistics functions
like for example empirical distribution
oh i i'm pretty sure all of the stat
ones support units
okay okay okay good
well then then the next thing will be
around
yep and like i said i'd be happy to
discuss that
discussion if jose were here but since
i don't i don't have the same view of
around as he does i i'd rather
not discuss it in his absence okay all
right
does anybody know what's happening just
another random
poke in the dark um uh
the time series stuff which i
also think has a bunch of consistency
issues
well i mean the redo of time series to
be more
better stronger allow time series that
aren't just
individual numbers but you know all
kinds of things like that
okay we need someone from the stats to
okay
sounds good all right well thanks all
very much
and uh see you another time thanks to
folks on the live